co-teaching with srini professor Serena
vests david s is really a lot of fun
we've taught before we taught the six
double O six it's on ocw together and
Serena is I would say one of the most
humorous professors that I know at MIT
so it's really a lot of fun to teach
with him and I mean sometimes it's like
a comedy routine in his lectures and I
like to do that too and lectures tell
lots of jokes and and play together so
it's really nice working together we
have a good dynamic for we're both super
flexible like oh I need you to cover
this lecture oh no problem i love that
stuff in fact we were both kind of
fighting over which lectures we wanted
to teach cooling I really want to teach
this no no I taught it i really want to
teach at this time and so that's the
nice dynamic to have it's not like oh
you taught one too few lectures is not
balanced totally totally not like that
and both in six double o 6 and 6 0 for 6
in the last lecture we do a kind of
actual comedy routine or were somehow
like finding each other it's all all in
good humor and it's pretty fun students
really like it he's also in both classes
he has creative ideas and how to reward
students for answering questions so in
six double 06 we were in a relatively
uncomfortable lecture hall and so we had
these pillows that we had custom printed
and had the name of the class and a
little Rubik's Cube on it and so if
anyone ever answered a question in class
or asked a good question then we would
throw them a pillow kind of like a
frisbee and so for 6046 srini is like
you know what we have to do this time is
get actual frisbees and so we got these
blue and purple frisbees also a custom
printed with the class number and a
little diagram that this is in lecture
20 or something and so whenever anyone
asks us or answered a question we would
throw them a frisbee and we make jokes
about whether blue was better or purple
was better there was no better it was
just so this is this is tough for me
because I had to really
how to throw frisbees but I think by the
end of the semester I got pretty good